hi my name is karina do i'm the
executive director of greenpeace
international and the question that I'm
asking is what do I really care about
and what I'm going to try to do about it
I'm deeply concerned about the future of
our children and grandchildren as a
result of the impending and fast
approaching climate catastrophe that we
are heading towards already around the
world mu 350,000 lives up in law static
uterine climate in taxi we are heading
in the direction that could potentially
threaten life on this planet as we know
it however the good news is we can turn
this crisis into an opportunity by
moving quickly decisively and with a
vision in the direction of the green
economy by investing in energy
efficiency and renewable technologies
not only will we be able to bring down
emissions and curb the worst impacts of
climate change but also will be able to
generate millions of new green jobs in a
new economy we can have a double win to
win for the environment climate and the
win for the economy and for social
justice it's important that we actually
recognize that sometimes we sound very
job and even say save the planet save
them vital and save the planet what the
struggle is about essentially is
securing our children and eventual his
future there can be nothing more
important than having a sense of
intergenerational justice and I think
sadly the adult population is failing us
at the moment and I invite and encourage
young people to step forward and take
leadership because you will pay the
biggest consequences and I caution you
not to put too much faith in the current
crop of adult leaders that we have
because some of them sadly are the
biggest bunch of losers you're going to
find a very nice tree of this planet
thank you very much